البقاء على قيد الحياة أمر غير عادي لأسباب ليس أقلها
أنها تحملت ثلاث مجاعات على مدار
قرنها وألقي اللوم فيها جميعًا على
الكرملين.
نحن نأكل الزيزفون وأوراق الزيزفون والقراص التي
استخدمناها لطحن هذه النباتات البرية في
خبز الزهور بها وأكلها
في سن 13 عامًا، رأتها أكبر سنًا.  يموت أخ وأخت في
أسوأ مجاعة جماعية في أوكرانيا،
الهولوديمور، كانت ساقاي منتفختين،
وتورمت ذراعاي، وكنت مريضًا جدًا لدرجة أنني اعتقدت أنني
سأموت
في أوائل ثلاثينيات القرن الماضي بناءً على أوامر جوزيف ستالين.
تم تجريد المزارعين الأوكرانيين
من كل الحبوب التي ينتجونها لإطعام
موسكو
أطفال صغار يموتون من الجوع،
تم نقلهم إلى شاحنة وحفروا
حفرة كبيرة وألقوا بهم جميعًا في
أوكرانيا، والآن بعد 11 شهرًا من
الغزو الروسي الأخير،
ثلاثة من أحفادها جنود
يقاتلون القوات الروسية لأن
الرئيس الروسي لا يصدق ذلك  أوكرانيا
موجودة
وتجدر الإشارة إلى أن أوكرانيا
لم يكن لديها في الواقع تقاليد مستقرة
للدولة الحقيقية. ادعى بوتين أن الهجوم الروسي
على العاصمة الأوكرانية كييف فشل
العام الماضي، ويعتقد العديد من الأوكرانيين أنهم
يقاومون محاولة أخرى للإبادة الجماعية،
ويجلس قادة ومنظمو الإبادة الجماعية في نفس المكان.  مكاتب في
نفس المكان في مركز هذه الأحداث
هي موسكو وهدف الدمار
هو أوكرانيا كأمة
تقول الحكومة الأوكرانية إن الآلاف من
المواطنين أجبروا على الدخول إلى
الأراضي الروسية وفقد 14000 طفل وملايين
عديدة من الأشخاص ماتوا في العديد من
المجاعات  إن ما جلبته روسيا إلى هذا
البلد خلال القرن الماضي هو
موضوع نقاش بين المؤرخين
ومحامو حقوق الإنسان سيناقشون ما إذا كان
ما يحدث اليوم يمكن
تعريفه على أنه إبادة جماعية أم لا، ولكن ليس هناك
شك في أنه على مدى المائة
عام الماضية، كانت العلاقة بين  لقد
كانت موسكو وأوكرانيا قاتمة،
ونحن بحاجة إلى إبادتهم حتى لا
يتبقى أي منهم، وعندها فقط يمكن أن
يكون هناك أي سلام
للمساعدة في المجهود الحربي، وهي تربط الخيش
في الشباك لتمويه القناصين،
ولكن ربما يكون ضحكها هو الذي
أبقاها.  الذهاب لسنوات عديدة
سام كايلي سي إن إن
[موسيقى]